vous lui avez dit que vous alliez poser
une question sur Zinédine Zidane non
mais ça va de soi en plus la question
posée sur Zinédine Zidane il ne la
comprend pas très bien enfin j'invite
tous ceux qui nous regardent et qui
n'ont pas vu l'extrait il en existe
encore en France malheureusement qui
n'ont pas vu cette extraits qui ne l'ont
pas encore lu et vu la question sur
Zidane c'est pas et lui le prend un
petit peu comme ça ce n'est absolument
pas de dire
vous avez fait une erreur il fallait il
ne fallait pas mettre d'idée des champs
il fallait mettre Zinédine Zidane pas du
tout la question c'était le Brésil c'est
une icône française Zidane le voir
partir vous en tant que Français voir
partir Zinédine Zidane dans une autre
sélectionner sélectionneur du Brésil
c'est vrai alors on va voir
sélection j'y crois à peine mais vous
avez le droit effectivement vous avoir
un avis tout à fait différent oui mais
je parlais pas forcément d'équipe de
France je parlais de le voir entraîner
notre sélection il a pas tenté de vous
joindre là ces derniers jours non
Zinédine Zidane
il se passe quelque chose et ensuite
évidemment sur les propos que vous avez
rediffusé sur les propos sur Zinédine
Zidane là on sent que ça va prendre une
ampleur mais franchement c'est surtout
le tweet de Kylian Mbappé qui donne une
dimension internationale on s'attend pas
comme ça à ce tweet de Kylian Mbappé qui
réagit très très vite Zidane c'est la
France on manque pas de respect à la
légende comme ça c'est fou parce que il
prend position alors que c'est évident
en fait c'est pas la première fois que
que les deux voilà on quelques
difficultés à s'entendre on se rappelle
que juste après le l'euro 2021
Kylian Mbappe a failli arrêter l'équipe
de France parce qu'il y a eu des propos
racistes sur les réseaux sociaux à la
suite de son pénalty de finale face à la
Suisse ils sont pas et qu'il aille lui
et Noël le grec n'a cessé de rappeler
que dans le foot le racisme n'existait
pas donc forcément Kylian Mbappé a un
peu de mal avec Noël le grec et bah il a
envie qu'il a envie qu'il soit déni de
ses fonctions faudrait lui poser la
question mais
on sent qu'il aime pas beaucoup quoi
alors justement avant d'entendre
Jonathan Zidane qui était qui avait
l'air très énervé euh celui-là la crèche
alors vous vous avez été choqué
forcément par l'interview de Noël le
Grey mais il est déjà il a déjà eu
quelques casseroles Noël le gars c'est
quoi pour les téléspectateurs qui
connaissent pas c'est le président de
l'Afrique il a eu quelques casseroles en
effet avec certaines employés de la FFF
la Fédération Française de Football la
Fédération Française de Football alors
c'est pas des il y a pas eu d'abus
sexuel mais il y a eu quand même des
messages très qui ont fait polémique ou
pour qu'une employée puisse accéder à un
certain poste il lui a proposé des
relations sexuelles dans sa chambre
d'hôtel quand même chez lui ou
des personnes qui lui ont répondu oui
mais non de toute façon moi je suis je
suis homosexuel je peux pas
ça me dérange pas moi Mathieu Delormeau
a proposé des cérébrations sexuelles
pour être chroniqueur dans TPMP c'est
toujours refusé
non en fait il a pas été parce qu'en
soit il y a pas il y a pas eu de
plaintes pour abus sexuel dans le sens
où il a jamais eu de gestes déplacés
physiques seulement envers des emplois
après c'est des choses qui sont on va
pas se mentir c'est c'est des secrets de
petits chinoise c'est caché au sein de
la Fédération Française de foot il y a
eu énormément de c'est à dire on le
savait ça avant mais on le sait depuis
que Romain Molina a publié plusieurs
articles pour plusieurs médias
par quelqu'un ce monsieur ben je vais
pas dire qu'il est protégé par quelqu'un
mais c'est le football ça reste quelque
chose qui est quand même très politique
il y a un audit en ce moment oui oui
justement il y a un audit mais l'audit
quand même politique
des sports se bouge et on va pas se
mentir quand romain Molina a sorti
toutes les toutes les enquêtes qu'il a
fait sur la
fédérations
un peu les abus sexuels qui avaient au
sein de la fédération les propositions
indécentes que certaines personne enfin
femme qui travaille à la Fédération
Française de foot peuvent recevoir avec
preuves à l'appui avec des témoignages
avec des peintres donc il y a énormément
de choses qui sont passées sous silence
et là la ministre des Sports je suis
désolé elle a réagi hier parce que on a
parlé de Zinedine Zidane et parce que
justement
je ne suis pas là pour parler
moi personnellement j'aime bien
Noël le grec je crois qu'elle veut sa
tête Gilles exactement et elle a obtenu
maintenant Laval ou le soutien au
d'Emmanuel Macron qui en aura le bol de
Noël le grès alors pourquoi alors pour
les téléspectateurs c'est quoi les infos
sur Noël de grec c'est quoi les
casseroles alors Noël le grec il y a
beaucoup de casseroles il y a il n'y a
pas de racisme dans le football sa
fameuse phrase qui avait fait scandale à
l'époque il y a des phrases sur les
joueuses les joueuses au féminin qu'elle
continue de se tirer par les cheveux
sexisme et discrimination donc il y a
beaucoup de phrases comme c'est ça qui
ont été prononcés qui ont donné lieu à
des petits avertissements verbaux
maintenant il y a l'audit et là c'est la
la goutte d'eau ultime c'est s'attaquer
à Zidane et là ça prend une proportion
dingue c'est à dire que tout le monde
dit on s'attaque à l'icône on s'attaque
à Zidane donc là il a atteint un tel
stade que peut-être à son âge doit-il
enfin passer la main c'est ce que
beaucoup de gens juste un mot parce que
par contre ça jeune personne alors tu
vas dire que je ramène tout le temps
tout le homosexualité mais c'est aussi
celui qui avait dit au début du Qatar
que l'homophobie l'homophobie c'était
culturel dans certains pays donc c'était
pas très grave il y a aussi sur les
chambres des ouvriers au Qatar il y a
une enquête où il dit bon juste un petit
coup de peinture ça évidemment ça a fait
beaucoup de mal aussi c'est une
catastrophe il y a eu beaucoup de
dysfonctionnements au sein de la
Fédération française de football c'est
pour ça aussi qu'il y a cette audit il
faut savoir que demain Noël le grep sera
de nouveau auditionné pour parler de ces
dysfonctionnements que cette audit les
conclusions sont rendus fin janvier
et qu'est-ce qui va se passer il peut se
faire virer ou pas ça c'est encore une
question c'est très compliqué qui peut
le virer qui peut le virer
personne ne peut pas percer en fait on
peut le virer et c'est quoi c'est sous
pression du président de la République
on l'a vu avec Bernard Laporte qui qui a
été condamné en premier instant ce qui a
fait appel et pourtant madame la
ministre améliore Castéra a essayé
d'écarter Bernard Laporte elle y arrive
donc peut-être que ce scénario pourrait
se reproduire pour eux
mais il y a que il y a que il y a que le
Président il y a que le président en
fait qui peut président Macron qui peut
c'est ça qui donne les subventions il y
a que l'État qui peut alors justement
alors Jonathan Zidane petite cousin
Zinédine toi tu as dû devenir fou hier
ouais moi j'ai pété un plomb la famille
vous dites quoi
déjà sous le choc après en se levant ce
matin surpris aussi et content de voir
les lents de solidarité des Français
personnalité publ et du peuple aussi
Didane on sait qu'il a pas besoin de
parler c'est que la France elle est là
pour lui et une fois de plus elle l'a
prouvé
sous le choc les propositions
qui ne reflètent absolument pas ma
pensée ni ma considération pour le
joueur qui était et l'entraîneur qui est
devenu chaque accordé un entretien RMC
que je n'aurais pas dû accorder car il
cherchait la polémique en opposant
Didier à Zidane deux monuments du
football français exactement
je veux au moins répondre là dessus on
sait que la meilleure défense c'est
l'attaque même si elle est grotesque
celle-ci est forcément grotesque parce
que j'ai envie de tout le monde encore
une fois à aller écouter ce qui s'est
passé sur RMC déjà en deux points c'est
une méconnaissance totale parce qu'il ne
connaît pas cette émission avec Marion
Bartoli Bartoli time on accueille plein
de grands champions il y a une Novak
Djokovic il y a eu Joey il y a eu Boris
dio j'espère que je serai invité pour le
paddle bien sûr évidemment en plus j'ai
toujours disque
qui sont déjà devenus et qui sont déjà
venus il y a Rogers Federer qui nous a
donné son accord personne ne sait jamais
plaint donc on invitera donc non avec
Marion Bartoli ça se passe toujours très
bien elle est très pro elle fait son
métier donc juste pour répondre sur le
point de de cette polémique et sur mes
questions j'ai deux questions la
première c'est est-ce que vous avez
appelé ou est-ce que Zinédine Zidane
vous a appelé c'est une question très
polémique imagine je vous pose la même
question est-ce que vous avez appelé
Louis Boyard bah non non bon voilà on en
reste là il y a pas de polémique oui en
plus nous on n'est pas fâché Zidane et
le grec donc c'est pas pareil voilà oui
mais on sait qu'il l'a pas choisi et la
deuxième question c'est de dire est-ce
que le côté brésilien ça vous gênerait
pour une icône française et là il me
répond j'en ai rien à secouer il s'est
piégé tout seul il a beau dire
maintenant et la Fédération abolir que
nous les avons piégés il suffit de
réécouter l'extrait ça tombe sous le
sous le bon le piège ça aurait été si
tu l'aurais appelé tu l'aurais dit on
peut s'appeler au téléphone pas filmé
oui ça c'est un piège mais là c'est la
question que ça fait banal c'est très
bien qu'on est en direct
il y a pas de raison de dire que ça a
été des questions pièges les réponses
c'est lui qui les a donné Géraldine
pourquoi tout le monde
le grecte mais parce qu'en fait il a des
casseroles comme vous l'expliquez tout à
l'heure mademoiselle parce que d'abord
je pense qu'il est beaucoup trop vieux
il a été maire de Guingamp il a été je
crois président de la ligue il a fait
des depuis très longtemps je pense que
c'est un homme fatigué et je pense que
voilà les gens les gens n'en veulent
plus à la télé
il y a des mecs de 80 ans
dès qu'il ouvre la bouche en fait
permettez-moi aussi de rajouter quelque
chose et je sais que c'est votre ami et
je pense que pardonnez-moi c'est un
énorme caillou dans la chaussure de
Didier Deschamps du tout il a rien fait
lui non mais il a rien fait malheur
j'aimerais petite histoire
ils ont tous défendu Zizou que fait
Didier Deschamps
aucun problème entre Didier Deschamps et
Zinédine ça sent encore
et je peux vous dire je pense pas que ce
soit c'est un proche de vous d'idée des
gens ah je le connais parce que c'est un
proche donc parler de ce que vous
connaissez rien à voir dans la première
fois
de parler 2 minutes
pour l'instant il est en train il est en
train de dormir il vient il vient de
prendre la parole pour dire qu'il allait
qu'il a des continuer d'idées des choses
pendant la parole quand il le voudra et
pour l'instant il sort d'une coupe du
monde on va le faire mais dans la sauce
parce qu'il dit ouais on dit on déjeune
ensemble
et on décide de la gouvernance ensemble
de mon successeur ensemble alors que lui
il a été prolongé pendant 4 ans et Noël
donc je trouve malgré très vite parler
et ce détacher s'il veut parler il parle
s'il veut pas parler
avec Gilles non mais tu connais rien au
foot toi qu'est-ce que tu connais non
mais c'est
[Applaudissements]
ce serait il consentir que de ne pas y
participer ça veut dire qu'effectivement
non mais attends mais c'était hier
matin il a su qu'il allait repartir pour
4 ans et c'est 2 secondes il a même pas
lui la polémique il savait pas qu'elle
allait arriver personne savait qu'elle
allait arriver il va y avoir un pas
président
et des champs tu me sortiras à tu me
sortiras de ma palmarès un plus grand
palmarès que celui de Didier Deschamps
en France
tu trouves toujours surprenant des
choses sur Didier Deschamps est-ce que
tu l'aimes pas et je ne le connais pas
pourquoi il n'a pas marché on a vu on a
vu ce que tu as vu sur
Twitter très facile il y en a d'autres
qui l'ont moi aussi ça vient de passer
quand il aura le faire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ce que veut dire Géraldine elle veut pas
du tout attaquer d'idée des champs on
sait qu'elle l'aime pas j'aurais été
quelqu'un d'autre qui le dit quelqu'un
d'autre qui le dit j'aurais dit oui j'ai
vraiment aussi que tu veux dire n'aime
pas Didier
Daniel n'aime pas beaucoup il a défoncé
la semaine dernière pendant 10 minutes
pourquoi pas oui je l'aime beaucoup
tu rentres le soir avec ton mari qui l'a
défoncé tu lui dis quoi je sais pas
quand il a défoncé pendant 9 minutes sur
RMC tu lui dis quoi ton mari vous prenez
la soupe
invitez mon mari et demandez-lui
qu'est-ce que tu lui dis mes amis
j'ai pas à lui dire
42 enfants quand il a défoncé
donc tu le défends bah bien sûr et je le
défendrai toujours j'ai toujours défendu
mes amis et je voulais la vérité Didier
Deschamps il y a même pas besoin de le
défendre ce qui n'est même pas dans la
sauce il est même pas dans l'histoire et
deux avec ce qu'il a amené avec ce qu'il
a amené à la France et tout et le
palmarès qu'il a on ferme notre gueule
et on dit bravo
je vais vous dire le vrai grosse merde
c'est que il a chez lui une intention de
nuire c'est ça que la France entière ne
peut pas lui parler il a une intention
de punir Zinédine Zidane en le en lui
tend le traitant comme merde c'est la
France ne lui pardonnera jamais ça c'est
ça en fait
alors dis-nous toi je suis venu ce soir
pour ben en fait pour pour les propos
qu'a tenu monsieur le grain alors
dis-nous on peut pas parler de Zidane
comme ça merci c'est une légende il a
jamais été dans aucune polémique la
toujours toute la portée pour la France
il a toujours
été là il a donné la victoire de la
finale de la Coupe du Monde 98 à
l'équipe de France sans lui aurait pas
bien sûr le premier étoile sur le
maillot qu'est-ce qu'il a fait 4 ans
après hein et et il a il a un coup de
bulle sur
des plus grands joueurs c'est le plus
grand joueur de l'histoire mais arrête
le foot que pour le moment de la coupe
du monde quand l'équipe de France est en
finale autrement je regarderai rien et
pour moi ça Zina effectivement c'est une
légende mais une légende elle peut aussi
elle elle a le droit de ne pas être tout
le temps sur un piédestal
je trouve ça con mais bon
il y a pas de crise
il n'y a pas de crime pour moi de l'aise
Zidane moi je ce que je ne comprends pas
c'est qu'un monsieur comme ça qui est
que on fasse ce circulation sur sur ces
phrases là alors que ce monsieur ça fait
longtemps qu'il devrait être viré pour
simplement la présomption de harcèlement
et de tout ce qui se passe il a pas
c'est là la vraie question
quand il y a des soupçons et quand il y
a tellement de choses qui pèsent sur sur
un moment
il y avait pas ses soupçons et forcément
c'est ça qui qui choque un petit peu les
Français le monde du foot c'est le côté
copinage le côté j'ai un petit peu court
c'est la Fédération Française de
Football et qu'au final bah c'est les
copains qui peuvent me lire donc j'ai
réussi à avoir un autre mandat c'est ça
qui est choqué mais ensuite sur l'audit
il y a quelque chose c'est en cours et
ça va arriver et là franchement
Noël le grec c'est un animal politique
on peut l'aimer ou ne pas l'aimer mais
il est très fort il a survécu à tout et
il se prend jusque-là du soutien du et
des présidents de la République à chaque
fois c'est un homme de gauche mais qui a
su évolué il était très proche des
présidents non non
il peut démissionner il ne le fera pas
il peut être il peut avoir un vote de
défiance du comité il ne l'aura pas
parce qu'il est tient donc la seule
façon
Emmanuel Macron effectivement décide de
le lâcher et donc une autorité naturelle
s'il y a une pression du président sa
position deviendra la politique
donc il peut faire ce qu'il veut
il a fait beaucoup pour la France le
Noël le Grey aussi le Gret j'ai pas le
contraire le un moment donné après des
propos comme ça si
dans les jours qui viennent il est pas
déni de ses fonctions par lui-même
c'est que c'est possible
tu crois qu'il va rentrer chez lui à
regarder des derricks sur son canapé
frère non mais c'est vrai il a il a tout
là il est il est président de la FFF
c'est incroyable je crois qu'il va
démissionnera jamais mais jamais de la
vie mais
il faut quand même se dire que c'est
peut-être je sais pas mais c'est
peut-être la goutte d'eau et c'est
peut-être l'affaire de trop et l'affaire
de trop ce sera peut-être celle avec
Zidane française vous l'avez déjà dit je
crois que c'est possible que ce soit
l'affaire de trop ce qui est possible
parce que c'est mon cousin mais bon
c'est mettre Zizou dans dans dans des
sauces comme ça
réagir pourquoi non
c'est comment on sait que il a un
tempérament ou il s'en fout un peu de
tout il fait sa vie il travaille sur le
travail
avec nous un empêchement elle m'a écrit
la peau voilà elle viendra nous voir
elle me diras vous avez vu qu'elle est
bon elle condamne ce qui a dit Noël le
voilà merci elle de m'a écrit un instant
parce qu'elle a un gros empêchement
voilà donc moi je pense aussi qu'il moi
je pense qu'il restera et je pense que
ça va se tasser bah voilà il y a les
deux plus grandes fédérations en France
le rugby Bernard Laporte a été mis de
côté maintenant c'est Noël le Gretz je
pense que la ministre des Sports et vous
l'avez rappelé il ne s'entendent
absolument pas même Noël le Great a
dérapé durant la Coupe du monde parce
que on lui a demandé déjà s'il avait vu
la ministre des Sports avec les bancs de
arc-en-ciel et lui il a répondu ah bon
elle était là et la deuxième c'est
vous avez vous entendez pas bien il dit
je sais pas je lui parle pas bah ça donc
déjà c'est chaud et donc forcément leur
relation sont très compliquées si la
ministre des Sports
veut vraiment faire quelque chose comme
Bernard Laporte je pense qu'à un moment
donné elle sera obligée de le faire
merci s'excuser donc je pense que c'est
à mon avis ça va passer aussi